you've given me here over two and a half
hours to talk expensively
sure but I'm grateful for it because I
think the public need and want
long form analysis of the UAP issue and
news Nation did that they created an
hour of prime time TV
um they've got the full interview with
Dave grush which I think runs about
three and a half hours I'd probably edit
it down to a tighter two hours I'd like
to run the the Fuller interview so that
people can see the full extensive
questions and answers that I put to Dave
and it would be my hope that in some
format we can run that at some stage
yeah what holds that back
uh good question you'd have to ask news
Nation
um I I'm hoping to be able to run it or
a version of a Dave grush interview on
need to know dot today at some stage
um if they're not going to uh because I
do think there's more material that
ought properly to be poured into the
public domain and I I think also people
want to see Rush being pressed in the
way that I did press him in the
interview I think in the news Nation
story
um they did a fantastic job really
professional job really proud to have
been working with them and I hope I can
continue to work with them in the future
but um the one thing I would have loved
to have seen more of is the competitive
interviewing and pressing of Mr grush
that we showed and the way that we
challenged him during the interview I
think people would understand more about
why I find Mr grush a highly credible
witness if they could see the question
and answer and Analysis that we do in
the course of the interview
and that's always a frustration with TV
because Network TV always wants to put
things into bite-sized chunks that fit
around the advertisements because
ultimately all news is is the stuff you
wrap around advertisements it's all
about selling selling Corn Flakes but
the um the the simple factors I think
the audience wants more and uh I'm
aspiring and hoping to be able to
provide them in some format with more
what a lot of people don't realize Kurt
is
um uh I laughed just recently because
somebody with Malayan intent created a
Wikipedia entry for me where they said
that cool tart
um is making the claims that he's making
in order to join the quote lucrative UAP
lecture circuit with Leslie Kane and
Ralph Blumenthal
and it's hilarious because I have never
earned a cent from any UAP lecture and I
really as you know I'm not being paid
for this interview with you where I've
given you nearly three hours of my time
and um frankly I I don't expect to be
and um or the work that I do is largely
unpaid and I do this work in conjunction
with an occasional day job that I do as
an investigative reporter for Australian
network television
and it's a hard gig they don't care that
you've had some Choice words about the
mainstream media
I think they share my view I mean I to
be honest with you I think most people
in mainstream media are depressed about
the way mainstream media is going it's
failing its audiences okay dumbing down
it's frightened of long-form analysis
and the irony is as the Dave Crush
interview showed when you give people
long-form analysis they love it they've
responded to it I mean news Nations
ratings were up multiple hundreds of
percent they're delighted with the
response that they had and I think
they've realized that this is a story
that should be being chased and more
importantly people have come out of the
woodwork and spoken to news Nations
supporting Dave crush's allegations in a
way that they didn't expect I think
they've been very pleasantly surprised
and I'm looking forward to making more
stories with them in the future you just
watched a clip from the theories of
everything channel for the full video
and all its magnificence then click here
and if you'd like to see more then
subscribe enjoy